haha the Joe Rogan experience that's my
favorite quote from Tarantino what I
sought interview one time and they were
saying like yeah we know it's trying to
write movies and stuff you know and they
were going like you can't do this you
can't do that he's like why maybe cuz I
do another [ __ ] I want
it's like that well that's why your
movies are great yeah what are you like
you just like that's that's the comic I
want to watch I can say whatever the
[ __ ] I want yeah good I want to see you
totally unfiltered yeah that's good I
mean there's a time in a place I think
you know you know to to be filtered sure
you know what I mean
there's no sense just going in and
showing your ass and being you know
right if somebody hires you for a
private gig and they go okay perform
between these two lines
you're not Lenny Bruce if you go in then
you go outside and you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right cuz you agreed to do that
right you do a corporate gig for a
Christian Church right but if you're at
like a comedy club it's like no you
you're a guest yeah you came into a
nightclub so right this isn't you know
if you don't like it you leave but I
came to see you
specifically and all the other people
did too and the one or two people
that'll get upset well you're the
problem the other people are there to
see this kind of [ __ ] it seemed so
selfish I'd be like if I went to a
restaurant and I didn't like the meal
and then the chef owed me an apology and
had to change his menu and you didn't
want anybody else to eat stop yeah I
hate this food and if you go in there
and eat off of that menu then you're
part of the [ __ ] problem and I'm
gonna try to take you down - yeah cuz
you didn't have a problem with this
[ __ ] chicken and dumplings whatever
the [ __ ] it's making yeah strange time
strange vest name special I feel yeah
well I didn't know what else to call it
just that's all I could think of yeah I
like it because it's not it's not you're
not punching them in the nuts you just
said strange it's a weird time yeah
paper tiger yep how long do you think
you're gonna wait until you do another
one do you have an idea in your head
you're gonna try to do two years we try
to do you have a set schedule never
think that no because that takes the
enjoyment out of it it's like more like
I had a bit that I was doing the first
time I told the story and my new
our two women like yelled out
simultaneously and they yelled the same
thing which means they whispered to each
other let's yell this in three two one
and I got out go [ __ ] yourself I got
into that with them and then they went
upstairs and I'm like it's a comedy club
I know they're still there because
comedy club security is the worst it's
the worst they just they just they they
don't know how to kick people out so I
went upstairs I had to put the hoodie up
and all of that [ __ ] they said they were
at the bar I walked by and then I go
outside the club took the hoodie up and
then they were there and then we got
into it again and I was just like you
don't even know me go [ __ ] yourselves
you know what the [ __ ] I'm saying [ __ ]
you [ __ ] with him Anna just my
perception on something I was telling a
[ __ ] story right so and it had to do
with a lesbian so that and then it was
the wrong show to do it on because I
think it was kind of a gay show I mean I
went up there they had paper cutouts of
dicks all over the place so I'm like I
but it's a comedy club so I'm telling
I'm telling the story I want to tell so
I told the story and you know so it took
me a little while you know to kind of
imagine I've pretty much of me it was
like you know I don't want to have that
kind of interaction with people so I've
just been you know working the bit out
working a bit out and then like you know
I did the joke the other night at the
Laugh Factory and the exact person from
that group came up to me told me she
loved the joke and she was just like I
feel like you would describe in my life
and I'm like that's why that's the fun
of this [ __ ] and you know as people say
like oh you're working out a joke I
can't do it at home yeah I have to go
out there and just start throwing [ __ ]
against the wall and see how to piece
this stuff together so to go back to
like when are you gonna do a special
again like I enjoy this part too much to
rush it we had to be thinking about like
you know then you're like okay I'm doing
is special I'm taping it here and then
I'm in the bubble and then every night I
go onstage and it's just like okay and
then I got to do this and maybe what if
I open with this and what if I put in
and just it just becomes
um you know this is added weight to it
mmm that makes it like you know the
opposite reason the entire reason why I
got into this business was not that
[ __ ] real job I wanted to have fun
so this which just goes back to what I
was talking about you when I was
watching us a flock Joe's on the other
side he shot his special and now he's
going down and as much as it can be
frustrating putting it together he's
having fun every night seeing alright
where's this idea gonna go yes it's
gonna leak cuz this sit like when I'm
putting together a new hour like I have
some of the hacky is [ __ ]
ever and I take all of those rules and
throw them out the window I don't give a
[ __ ] if you see me doing these jokes and
most of them don't live but some of them
grow into something better yeah and then
it's not hacky and now it's this this
thing that then shoots off into this and
then you just start spinning off over
here yeah yeah and then all of a sec
eight minutes I got 12 minutes they're
seeds right yeah it's starting to come
together so when people go down there
and it's literally like it's not even
done you're just starting to draw and
they're reacting to it saying it sucks
and it's like it's it's not done I'm
just yeah I agree with you it sucks yeah
yeah yeah I'm with you yeah this is our
work out but some people know that some
people understand that some people think
they come to see if most product most
people now today in 2019 yeah crowds are
great yes just one person in 50 shows
complains and it's you know because
there's so much [ __ ] to look at like
controversy gets people to stop at your
website and then you get credit from the
advertisers in the side and then they
they gas up [ __ ] and they donate they
you know I saw a guy recently talking
because you know suede everyone in the
internet hates me but I walk down the
street and everybody loves me so it's
just like so what is what's really going
on there's what's going on is is the
small that percentage that don't like
you is being shown to be the majority
you know well it's a very vocal minority
who get upset about things and they're
very they're adamant about it and
they're very active that's what it is
the people that are upset
certain things people that are in the
really respond specifically it's long if
you know because then you can do exactly
nine times out of ten exactly what
they're complaining is being done to
them they turn around and then do trying
to find their justice and they just I
don't know the irony seems to be lost on
these people but like I don't talk about
I try not to talk about that [ __ ] a lot
because I don't want to give it any more
added weight than it deserves and it's
just like bullies if people bring it up
I just say you know not everybody's
gonna like me yeah I I don't know what
to tell you I don't need everybody need
enough people to fill up enough of
wherever I'm playing so I can continue
doing this
[Applause]